my math high school teacher uh
his name is uh
he suffered from als oh wow and and uh
yeah he was a person that me and the
rest of the class uh admired he was the
person who was doing ski and
diving and everything and
we witnessed his
the progression of
his condition and it was
heartbreaking
and i think that was the the feed
i would say of my interest in in in the
brain
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders and meet
xiv coutierelli the ceo of manfort a
startup that provides a standard
neurological assessment in the clinic
and home
doctor cotielli holds a bachelor's and
master's degree in electrical
engineering and a phd in brain science
dr yakutiali has been connecting between
neurology and technology for over 20
years and has been working in the
israeli high-tech industry primarily and
intel's design center haifa israel
brain science phd entrepreneur ceo
what what led you into brain
study in the first place how does one
get into neuroscience to the depth that
you've decided to go into
um for me it was the kind of
i think a personal uh journey
that started the
when i was a teenager
as a kid
it was clear to me that i'm gonna
handle something to do with the
electronics and i was one of the kids
who spent hours with the lego and
disassembling tvs and all that
i didn't think much about the brain
um it was
a
my high school teacher uh
um my math
high school teacher
his name is
who was a great teacher i think the best
i ever had and
he suffered from als
oh wow and and uh yeah he was a person
that me and the rest of the class uh
admired he was the person was doing ski
and
diving and everything and uh
we witnessed this uh
the progression of uh
his condition and it was uh
heartbreaking
and i think that was the the speed
i would say of my interest in in in the
brain
and
after the army i started to
contemplating between uh
my favorite thing engineering but also i
started uh thinking about becoming a a
brain surgeon
maybe to help people uh that that suffer
from these kind of conditions i ended up
studying um electrical engineering at
the picnic but but
i was already
kind of uh hooked
to the brain so i started studying uh
biology and chemistry and our physiology
and all of that and
for my first degree
in parallel to the regular curse of the
electrical engineering training i took
uh i i connected between the
neurals and and the transistors
and then it's called multi-electrode
arrays that you
plant
neurons on top of it and then it's
connected to a chip and then later in my
phd between electrodes that you implant
on people's uh
brain and to pieces so
i've been connecting between technology
and roger for for now for 20 years
and
for most of the time i was working for
some high-tech companies like intel and
the academic
was the kind of i would say a hobby
until a certain moment that i decided
that
that's what i want to do also for a
business and this is uh
the starting point of firm on four
so
this idea of you know we have academia
we dive deep we do research right the
traditional route
for hundreds of years
for these types of things
the the the jump or the leap to now
making it into a business right and you
have to decide whether to spend the
majority of your time as a researcher or
the majority of your time as an
entrepreneur
what was that what was that decision
like for you what were sort of the pros
and cons because i'm sure that you know
pursuing it you know completing a phd in
brain science it's it's not trivial for
everybody to go straight into you know
the business world what were some of the
considerations for you
so
for most part i would say that uh and
and for me it was a bit frustrating i've
seen
not only my my own research but but
much more advanced and
i think better research conducted by
other people not
uh getting realized as as something that
helps people i mean you do very
exciting work and you get
you have some new findings and you
publish the results but at the end of
the day when you when you
try to evaluate
how many people's lives
have you changed it's it's for the most
part it's very little of course there
are some major
um discoveries that affect everybody but
but i think that very often
the research remains uh as a theoretical
uh thing and and for me it was a
troubling
and um actually
um i had these ideas of that i
brought from the academy that i
presented to a neurologist about
designing a ship again that we can
implant on people's brain and this is
something that i also got intel involved
that we will manufacture these ideas and
then
one of the neurologists that i've been
talking with
uh told me something like um
that every couple of months an engineer
like me
comes to his office with with an idea
for a new chip or a new solution when in
fact what they actually need
is a better means to
use the existing drugs the existing
medical devices and then when i asked
why uh
or what's the problem that they're
facing he said that
they essentially they know very little
about the patient that they're treating
because the entire evaluation is based
upon short and infrequent clinical
visits
everything is done even when the patient
arrives to the to the clinic it's all
done in a very subjective manner
outside of the patient's natural life
and this impairs the quality of care and
as a result a lot of people suffer more
than they they need and he told me that
this is this is one of the problems that
they would like engineers like me uh to
solve
he showed me a patient that was running
a test in in one of the latitude
corridor
uh and then uh later on um i i asked my
my friend from intel who is now moon
ford's cto dima i asked him if he thinks
that we can use smartphones
to
run the same test
in a digital manner
and a couple of days later we had a
prototype
for that particular test and then this
is how one more fourth started and and
we just added more and more tests to
evaluate more and more symptoms and this
is one of the things
that can make the largest impact there
will there's still room for new devices
there's still
room for more discoveries
but
i think that in order to start a
business you first
need to find the the unmet need
uh
in the industry or the market
to which uh you want to sell your
product that's from the business point
of view
i think that one one of the
fascinating lessons that i want to just
quickly extract from this what are you
just saying you know you're you know
you're you're describing a world that is
so deep tech right that the
the the break the entry the barrier of
entry for an entrepreneur in the brain
science world is very very high right
much more than a lot of other verticals
yeah and you're coming with a phd in
this subject your domain expert of this
and what you're learning
through the market is that the what the
world needs right now the biggest impact
you can have with your knowledge
understanding is not necessarily to
develop the new research paper right and
to advance brain science even further
right now what we need is the connection
between the existing research which is
already interesting to the patients
today and and the word and sort of this
path of how we as humans regular people
experience the technology versus where
it's at this gap is what you're able to
mitigate now through montford and that's
both a great business opportunity but
also
really really high impact for the world
right
correct and it's very often that
um again
i don't want to disregard
inventions like
my world like uh
pet and then the
mri which utilizes the most advanced
technology that the human race are have
invented
so that's important
and uh
it's very good that people spend a lot
of uh time and and i i i guess a couple
of nobel uh
uh prices were contributing to to mri
for example
but that's one field of of uh science
and research that um
brings something new but how many people
uh need mri and go uh to it i mean
it's what what most people need in in
terms of neurology is just for someone
to properly evaluate
their tremor of the hand for example
or um some decline in their
short-term memory
or how stable do they stand is if a
person
falls an elderly person falls
um
and and break a bone
most chances that they will die
as a consequence of this um
a
minor event no for fmri or bet or
whatever will help them so if if you
come up with
a
simpler solution than mri it still
requires a lot of understanding and
clinical validation etc but it's much
more simple that can minimize the risk
of faults for example you can help
millions of people all over the world
incredible right and obviously impact is
the is the theme here is something that
you know and then i can only imagine
the the way that
this accessibility
is going to change how we we think
through our diagnosis the the way in
which we we measure things that our
interaction with with
with doctors and obviously lowers what
we've been seeing with covet 19 and the
acceleration and the catalyzation
towards digital health telehealth that's
all in line with what you're doing with
munfort
what share with me a bit about the
strategy of the company what are what is
the actual product how does how do
customers
experience it and what are some of the
challenges that you as an entrepreneur
have to deal with in running munfort so
what we offer is a standard and digital
tool
to assess neurological symptoms
um
we look at it in in three main
categories
motor symptoms cognitive symptoms and
effective symptoms more related to
psychiatry which is also
um related to to the brain
we use smartphones to
um capture these symptoms in a
quantitative way this can be done in the
clinic this can be done in the
patient's uh real world
and so this is the the basic product now
um in terms of the go to market we
started
by validating and demonstrating uh the
capabilities of this solution first of
all in in the clinics
so we collaborated with hospitals
relating with leading neurologists
and we demonstrated that what we measure
from the smartphone
is at least as good as what they can
measure
and very often even
better than that because we compared
the smartphone capabilities to those of
uh very sophisticated labs that use all
sorts of sensors and and cameras etc
so that was the first uh thing um it
required a lot of uh
recruiting a lot of patients clinical
trials uh and uh publications
that led to
fda clearance that we've already
obtained for
several most of the tests that we offer
so that's the first thing that clearly
this is a must for the medical world to
to accept then
we started to look into the distribution
channels
and
we
now focus on um the pharmaceutical
industry and the medical device
manufacturing what we offer them is a
way to make their solution
tele-neurology compatible
they are looking for something that you
called as beyond the pill solution so to
whichever drug that the patient is being
prescribed
there's
going to be um a monitor attached to it
so
it can offer chronic care management
so they the the patient and and the
physicians are no longer disconnected as
they are now so if you'd buy a drug
uh that's treating parkinson or multiple
sclerosis or whatever
it will already include the monitor that
will allow your
physician
to understand if the treatment is
effective the dosage the frequency when
to take uh to optimize the treatment and
doing that in in in a much shorter time
than it would uh require firm okay so
that's the value uh proposition that we
offer
and uh
the next stage this is what we're
starting now
is to offer our solution to the
telehealth
companies
which have a different
channel to the to the patients they
work directly with a lot of members
they
know how to provide taylor diabetes for
example and telecardiovascular because
there are there are devices that can
connect between the cardiologists and in
the patient at home to measure their
heart rate for example and we offer them
an opportunity now
to offer tele-neurology
as a vertical of
of tele-health so that's the stage of
what we're doing now and we're already
looking into um
offering this solution
to the payers
the the insurance companies for example
and and if they
um
enforce this kind of uh um
daily enrollment and quality of care
into their services
uh it will save them a lot of fair money
it will
result with a much more efficient
treatment for
millions of millions of
patients so these are the stages that
we're
taking in where we are now
wow that's very very cool are there any
concerns about
you know could consumer behavior or
anything of that sort that you know that
of how we're going to be experiencing
this technology and this interaction
with the medical world are there any
questions that you're asking yourself as
a ceo and as a leader of this
so
medicine in general is
um
a very
i would say traditional
occupation by nature and and
it's good that it's uh
like that um there's a lot of wisdom and
knowledge
um in in medicine in general
and i think that neurology is even more
strict
than other um
conditions in adapt adopting new
technologies because
the brain is is a much more complicated
organ than anything that exists in in
our body it has dimensions of
of uh
work
uh that that you don't have in the
kidney or heart or lungs
so it's much more complicated to to to
treat it
it's much more complicated to handle uh
clinical trials in the in the brain
so neurology is even a bit more i would
say traditional than other fields of
medicine um
so it's it's a challenge to shift them
from the way that they're used to to do
the the
clinical the evaluation of the patient
in the clinic to something that uh to
rely
upon tests that the patient would
conduct uh at home
uh one thing that we've decided to do
after
learning uh
by our own mistakes is that uh
what helps them is not to invent any new
tests
that they are not familiar with
but
they offer a digital manner to conduct
a test that they there they know they
trust and this is much more easy for
them to to accept
and then once you you demonstrate that
it's working in the clinic the digital
test is performing as good as what
they're used to in a subjective
assessment in the clinic now you can
tell them to take another step further
and and and ask them to rely upon the
task that will run at the patient's home
and and later on and i can
tell you that
in the future and this is something that
we're already in the process of of uh
offering and including into our platform
more and more of the symptoms will be
evaluated
in a passive manner
so for example there's a test a classic
test that is called a tapping test where
the patient is asked to tap between
his fingers
we have a digital test
to to run it
and but you can get similar indication
indication by analyzing the the typing
patterns when you're texting someone so
it will take time to convince the
neurologist that they can rely upon the
passing data collection that acquires
for a lot of different things
but now we have this kind of a pillar
of the active and standard tests that
they know of
that we can run at the patient home
so this is making um
it a lesser challenge for them to to
adopt
and at the end i think what obviously is
a huge factor here is that you are a
doctor with a phd in brain science and
and you know so it's not you're not just
developing you know a nice application
that has a
very very you know limited foundation
for science you're saying we are a deep
tech science company we understand this
world we are looking for ways to to to
combine the research and the consumer
behavior in the passive behavior that we
do in the day to day and i think that is
really where the where the huge impact
is and it sounds fascinating and i
really want to thank you for those uh 20
short but meaningful minutes fascinating
work awesome journey and and i love the
sort of the way that you're thinking
through this and at the end it's all
about consumer behavior and how do we
connect you know what's happening around
the world in the research world to our
you know regular life and uh i love it
so
zev thank you very very much and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you very
much
[Music]